[Música]
economía en directo américa de franz a
24 y ya está conmigo en el estudio
daniela brandon dan y me encanta
compartir con usted pero en estos
tiempos verla es decir fue muchas malas
noticias malas noticias siempre voy a
tratar de
matizar las un poquitico porque después
brillará una pandemia ni las grandes
tecnológicas ahora pasan por un mal
momento si raúl pues mira estamos en ese
dilema de si estamos o no en recesión en
eeuu unos dicen que si otros dicen que
no lo cierto es que no está escrita
sobre piedra la fórmula que diga si hay
recesión en todo caso esos temores de
que haya eventualmente una recesión han
llevado al mercado de la publicidad
digital a reducir sus apuestas si bien
muchas de estas empresas siguen
reportando buenas ganancias las grandes
tecnológicas no están cumpliendo con las
expectativas de wall street
algunas inclusive dicen que van a
ralentizar el ritmo de contrataciones
por ejemplo estamos hablando de meta que
como lo sabemos es la casa matriz de
facebook e instagram que redujo sus
ingresos trimestrales por primera vez en
la historia
además por una intensa competencia de su
rival tick tock aunque éstos siguen en
niveles cercanos a los 30 mil millones
de dólares pero facebook no es la única
ni no señor no es la única que tengo
toda la lista mary comencemos por
alphabet esa es la casa matriz de google
cuyo crecimiento fue el más lento en dos
años y la causa pues el retiro de muchos
anunciantes que habían aprovechado en
pandemia cuando los consumidores estaban
acorralados en su casa para invertir más
en el caso de apple sus ganancias
trimestrales cayeron 10 por ciento
estuvo afectada por el cierre de
fábricas de iphone y otros productos en
china en medio de estos nuevos brotes de
kobe de 19 ahora vamos con microsoft que
depende de los ingresos por licencias de
los fabricantes que instalan su sistema
operativo windows sus ingresos subieron
12 por ciento en el trimestre sin
embargo también sufrió por los cierres
en china por un mercado de computadores
personales que está en franco deterioro
y hasta el fortalecimiento del dólar
porque porque encarece sus productos
raúl finalmente pues nuestra favorita
twitter
los ingresos y ganancias ya lo habíamos
dicho en otro de nuestros programas y lo
atribuyo por supuesto a la incertidumbre
por la venta ahí no nos cambiamos de
tema ahora ni nos venimos a nuestra
región porque un revolcón ministerial
económico en donde en argentina claro
que si raúl pues ni siquiera ha pasado
un mes desde que aquí estábamos hablando
de la posesión de silvina batakis en la
cartera de economía y ya tiene un
reemplazo muy cercana a la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández va a
ataques había llegado tras la renuncia
de martín guzmán prometiendo enderezar
ese difícil camino económico del país
ahora pasará a dirigir el estatal banco
nación después de que el presidente
alberto fernández nombrará a sergio
massa en un cargo que se ha denominado
como superministro él va a ser el
encargado de los temas de economía
agricultura y manufactura se preguntarán
por qué estos cambios pues la prensa
local lo atribuye a tensiones entre
diferentes a las de la coalición
gobernante de centroizquierda sobre cómo
abordar esta espiral de precios cada vez
más alta así como las enormes de deuda
que tiene el país y un peso que no hace
sino marcar máximos históricos si esta
rencilla que hay entre el presidente
fernández y la vicepresidenta cristina
dan y más crecimiento pero también más
inflación donde en la zona euro claro
raúl pues la economía de la zona euro
creció 4% interanual en el segundo
trimestre esto parece una buena noticia
es mucho mejor de lo esperado sin
embargo los economistas creen que ésta
podría ser la última sonrisa de la
economía antes de que la inflación cada
vez más alta y los problemas también de
la cadena de suministro provoquen una
leve recesión en la segunda mitad del
año
en efecto hablemos de precios mire el
aumento de los precios al consumidor en
los 19 países que comparten el euro se
aceleró a un nuevo récord del 8,9 por
ciento interanual en julio vamos ahora a
ver cómo se comportan los mercados
hablemos de los indicadores económicos
bueno en asia el índice de referencia de
hong kong se hundió más del 2 por ciento
después de que los líderes de china
reconocieran que la economía en apuros
no va a alcanzar su objetivo principal
de crecimiento del 55 por ciento este
año entre tanto las acciones europeas
operan significativamente al alza
después de los datos revelados sobre
crecimiento y a pesar de esta fuerte
inflación que apunta a nuevas alzas en
las tasas de interés veremos entonces
también cómo abre estados vamos a ver
entonces qué pasa en eeuu en cuanto a
eso danny y le pregunto qué nos tiene
hoy como cifra el día bueno que tanto le
gustan los chocolate raúl me encantan
los chocolates annie porque no vaya a
ser una mala noticia por favor no es no
bueno es medio mala noticia sí señor es
mala noticia para usted no tanto para mí
que me da como mi cara no le gusta pero
le tengo un dato mide 10% de las ventas
anuales representa la temporada de
halloween para la multinacional hertz y
que es la más grande fabricante de
chocolates de eeuu y usted se preguntará
por qué en julio sigue hablando de
halloween pues porque está que es la
dueña de marcas como kitkat o en la
mantequilla inclusive de maní gris que a
mí no me gusta o no me gusta reconoció
que no va a alcanzar a satisfacer la
demanda para su mejor época
debido a la escasez de materias primas
como cacao o aceite todo eso derivado de
la crisis de suministros y también de la
guerra en ucrania sin embargo dice que
si las ventas van a ser mejores pero no
precisamente porque venda más sino
porque lo va a vender más caro claro por
supuesto ahí no van a perder de ninguna
manera no se dan y como siempre gracias
a nuevos más adelante como esa economía
y nos vamos hasta miami